i just want to talk a little bit to you
about
the fact that it does feel one of the
best bits of news to emerge more
recently is that if you are admitted to
hospital
with covert 19 you've got a much better
chance of survival than at the beginning
of the pandemic
so back in march 66 of people
hospitalized with covered worldwide
survived
compared to 84 in august
why do you think that is um
we don't know for sure why that is but
but we we can speculate and if you think
back to sort of february march time this
year
we were facing a new disease we didn't
know how people responded to it
and we were trying to learn from people
around the world particularly china and
italy
about their experiences so we were faced
with the unknown
we were also faced with a huge influx of
of people who were sick with it who are
coming to hospital
and requiring critical care and that put
huge pressures on our capacity both in
terms of physical space but also
staffing as well and what's happened
over that period of time is that we've
learned about the disease
so we know how to treat patients earlier
um initially we used to put patients
um straight onto mechanical ventilation
so we bring them to intensive care
sedate them and put them on ventilators
but we slowly started to realize that
perhaps we could manage
some patients without doing that so
using
other modes of ventilation what we call
cpap
which is all the space helmet type
equipment that we've seen
in the media and so we were able to
reduce the number of patients that
required mechanical ventilation and
hence that probably had an impact
on on outcome but again what we've seen
is the demands on hospitals and critical
care
meant that we had to change our approach
to delivering care to patients
and as the pandemic went through its
course and we look at mortality
towards the middle to end of july
most intensive care units will have been
back to their normal
staffing ratios which meant we were
better able to provide
the same standard of care that we would
normally do
so it's probably a combination of things
but there is no doubt
that if you become sick with covid if
you come into hospital and certainly if
you are
admitted to an intensive care unit you
have a much better chance of surviving
now than you did
at the beginning of the year yeah
genuinely uh sort of good news
reassuring
um there has been some speculation that
it could be because the virus is
mutating to become weaker or because
people are getting a
lower viral load because of social
distancing do you think either those
things could be having an impact as well
i've not heard anything that would
suggest that the
nature of the virus has changed and
i i'm sure that you know as as sir
jeremy um
just mentioned that that many many
people
are actually listening to the guidance
we're not
um socializing as much and that will
have had an impact in terms of community
transmission
but it is still a very deadly virus so
although the majority of people
still who who become infected will have
a very very minor
illness or may not even know that
they're ill at all
for those people that require hospital
admission
for those that come to intensive care
it's still a very
severe disease and we certainly see in
critical
care that patients are extremely sick
and we've seen the images on
on on tv from inside liverpool hospital
and that you know that the staff are
working really hard their patients are
really sick and so it's it is important
that we
appreciate that the disease is still
there it's still
severe and if you end up in critical
care with covert pneumonia
you're almost twice as likely to die
than somebody who's admitted with a
pneumonia not due to covid
so it's still something to be worried
about really important um
distinctions there you were talking
there about the situation in some
hospitals in the areas that have been
worse
hit more recently because
hospitalizations really are starting to
tick up again so
what is the situation in intensive care
and
how concerned are you about nhs capacity
because we have heard of some
hospitals in nottingham liverpool
already beginning to cancel non-urgent
appointments
i think it's very different around the
country
you know we've seen the hot spots on the
the maps that we see on the
media and certainly the north west and
northeast yorkshire and humber
um parts of the midlands are are
affected and liverpool in particular
as we're all aware of um and in those
critical care units
what everyone is trying to do is unlike
the first wave where almost all
normal nhs activity was stopped apart
from urgent and emergency care
we don't want to see the unintended
consequences of that during this
next wave so we're trying to make sure
that we have
safe pathways for patients with covid
and those
without covid so that we can continue to
treat
everybody that needs to come to hospital
and so what that means is in intensive
care units at the moment
not all of those patients will be sick
with covid because we are continuing to
do
as much normal activity as we can
but unfortunately if covid continues to
rise in terms of community transmission
that is
by definition going to translate into
more patients in hospital
and more patients and critical care and
therefore the only way we can do that is
by stopping
non-urgent care and so the consequences
again this time round isn't going to be
on covered patients getting access to
health care it's going to be for those
patients that
don't have covid so it may well have an
impact on people who have chronic ill
health who need to have surveillance
it may be pregnant women who need
antenatal care
who may be scared to come forward
because they don't want to either risk
becoming infected or they don't want to
overburden the nhs and that is the one
thing that we we want to avoid this time
so if we can keep community transmission
down
it means that we can treat everybody
that needs health care and that is the
great desire for everyone working in the
nhs at the moment